Elena Volochine bonjour vous êtes notre
spécialiste bien sûr des questions
russes et mobilisées sur nos antennes
depuis depuis même vendredi soir et
l'annonce de ce début d'un coup de force
de vie privée alors je le disais il y a
un instant énormément d'incertitude
beaucoup de questions encore à leur où
l'on se parle du côté des certitudes
aujourd'hui
où en est-on alors c'est vrai qu'on a
passé tout le week-end à analyser les
différents scénarios et essayer d'en
savoir plus Le ceux qui se ce que l'on
peut dire aujourd'hui de façon avec une
certaine dose de certitude parce qu'il
faut toujours être prudent évidemment on
est dans un événement géopolitique sans
précédent depuis la chute de l'URSS
c'est que il y a quelqu'un en Russie ou
au pluriel qui veut renverser Vladimir
Poutine et il y a eu une tentative de
coup d'état avec cette ce coup de force
de Virginie Prigogine maintenant comment
le scénario de comment cela s'est
déroulé exactement qui est vraiment à
l'origine de ces de cette initiative ça
c'est un certain on ne sait pas aussi ce
qui s'est passé après c'est à dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a de gagner
Prigogine n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout
est-ce qu'il a été lâché par ces
soutiens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi a-t-il fait demi-tour ça c'est
extrêmement confus dans tous les cas
Vladimir Poutine se sent aujourd'hui
fragilisé le régime vacille on le voit
non seulement à travers ce que montre
les chaînes de télévision russe parce
que vous savez que je regarde beaucoup
la télévision russe il y a toujours
beaucoup beaucoup de déclinaisons des
thèses de base de la propagande
c'est-à-dire que Vladimir Poutine le
ministère de la Défense donne une thèse
et la propagande russe le décline à
l'infini l'amplifie par exemple voilà
nous avons détruit tant de cible
ukrainiennes militaires va dire
Igor conation le porte-parole du
ministère russe de la Défense et la
propagande va dire que que
se déroule comme prévu que toutes les
ciblons ont été atteintes que les nazis
sont en train de trembler que l'Occident
est en train de vouloir détruire la
Russie etc et il va y avoir des
émissions à l'infini pour décliner tout
ceci sur les chaînes de télévision russe
ce que l'on voit depuis
vendredi soir depuis samedi et ce
dimanche c'est que les journaux
télévisés russes les chaînes
d'information continue la chaîne
d'information en continu aussi à 24 les
présentateurs ne font que lire les
communiquer officielles il n'y a
quasiment pas de de commentaires il n'y
a quasiment pas de déclinaisons il est
reportages sont très très courts donc on
voit qu'il y a vraiment une fébrilité
qu'il y a vraiment une reprise du
contrôle aussi à 24 diffuse à longueur
de journée des documentaires historiques
enfin on est quand même dans une
situation
biaisée évidemment tendancie en lien
avec le thème des traîtres de la
rébellion des terroristes etc à mater
mais on est quand même dans une
situation où il y a des événements sans
précédent et on sent qu'il y a vraiment
un contrôle sur la communication et puis
cette vidéo ce matin de Sergueï ministre
de la défense avec l'un des généraux
responsables de l'opération spéciale sur
la ligne de front il y a présenté une
vidéo présentée comme étant chaque blue
alors en Ukraine sans qu'on sache
véritablement si c'est exactement il
s'agit effectivement une vidéo sans son
comme la dernière fois que j'ai vu des
vidéos sans son circulées
de la part de du ministérius de la
défense c'était lorsque le croiseur
moscva le navire amiral de la flotte
russe avait été coulée par l'armée
ukrainienne et que autre moment de faire
que le ministère russe de la Défense
autrement en février et que le ministère
russe de la Défense cherchait à cacher
le nombre de morts et d'ailleurs parmi
les soldats russes et d'ailleurs
présents sur ce bateau et ne l'a
toujours pas révélé dans son intégralité
donc voilà le régime vestige Vladimir
Poutine on l'a vu il est sorti de sa
réserve avec cette vidéo de 5 minutes
où il a appelé à l'unité où il a appelé
au statu quo aussi où il a dit il a
réaffirmé du coup son soutien à Sergueï
choue et Valérie guerassimov il ne l'a
pas dit mais il a dit que voilà l'armée
russe devait reprendre la que tout
devait rester en place en gros il a
gagné Prigogine quant à lui c'est
attaqué
donc quelque part dans cette tentative
de coup d'État il laissait une porte de
sortie à Vladimir Poutine Vladimir
Poutine a fait comprendre que voilà que
tout devait être maintenu qu'il est
voulait se maintenir au pouvoir avec ses
cadres pour le moment on voit
aujourd'hui Serge donc voilà le le le
après il y a une négociation et on ne
sait pas quels en ont été les termes
voilà alors autre question à poser ce
matin sur lequel on a besoin de de vos
éclaircissements Elena Vladimir Poutine
a qualifié il a gagné Prigogine de
traître samedi matin lors de son
intervention à ce stade on ne sait pas
où est venu Prigogine mais il aurait
obtenu dit-on l'immunité pourquoi à quel
titre s'il est comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure éventuellement le pion de
quelque chose qui le dépasse d'une
certaine façon et qui visait peut-être à
renverser Vladimir Poutine pourquoi
cette pourquoi cette immunité
on va être pourquoi l'immunité parce que
il fallait résoudre la situation de
façon très vite et urgente et il fallait
qu'il y ait gagné Prigogine accepte
d'arrêter tout simplement
il fallait une négociation il fallait un
compromis il a l'immunité aujourd'hui ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il l'aura encore
demain
effectivement l'immunité donnée en
public comme ça à gagner Prigogine on
peut au moins supposer que pour un temps
ce sera vrai il peut très bien aussi
demain retourner soi-disant sur la ligne
de front parce qu'il ne va sans doute
jamais vraiment en première ligne et
être attaqué on peut l'empoisonner on
peut aussi lui garantir l'immunité mais
chercher à l'éliminer physiquement d'une
façon ou d'une autre il faut vraiment
comprendre que que là on va être dans
une période où le régime va sortir tout
ce qu'il peut comme arme que ce soit le
poison noviccioc que ce soit ces
assassins partout dans le monde que ce
soit une restructuration en interne de
son armée dont on pourrait ne pas
entendre parler non plus mais là on
entre dans la chasse aux traîtres là on
montre bien sûr bien sûr le régime va se
durcir on entre dans une chasse aux
traîtres il va falloir être extrêmement
prudent sur les affirmations avec la
propagande aussi parce qu'il y aura
beaucoup de propagande dans cette
période où le régime va tenter de de
s'accrocher et de se maintenir donc il
faut vraiment être très prudent sur les
affirmations où sont les wagnères ou les
Prigogine sur ce que dit le Kremlin sur
ce que dit Prigogine sur ce que pourrait
dire d'autres acteurs de cette crise il
faut être vraiment très prudent parce
que il faut accepter aussi qu'il que
tout ça va être qu'ils vont tenter de
rendre cela opaque un maximum possible
manipuler les médias pour par exemple
donner ce genre vous garantie pour
ensuite éliminer l'ADV l'adversaire vous
savez il y a une femme qui a dit une
chose très juste une russe dans l'un de
nos reportages hier réalisé par Claire
pakalin cette russe exilée qui a dit on
lui a demandé ce qui se passait et il a
dit mais c'est une bande de bandits et
on pouvait absolument s'attendre à ce
qu'ils finissent par se par se bouffer
la gueule en fait et c'est extrêmement
exact c'est aujourd'hui c'est une mafia
qui arrivait au pouvoir depuis plus de
20 ans en Russie qui est en train de
régler ses comptes qui est au pouvoir
qui est aux manettes aujourd'hui c'est
le clan de Saint-Pétersbourg Vladimir
Poutine et les oligarques qui ont monté
leur business ensemble avec des
milliards et des milliards et des
milliards de roubles pour en payant les
ressources du pays parti dans les offres
ils sont riches à l'infini aujourd'hui
ces gens-là donc au départ je vais en
venir à prix goji parce que c'est très
important qui gouverne le pays ça c'est
le clan des civils qui gouvernent le
pays avec le clan de ce que ce que l'on
appelle les cilos Vicky c'est à dire les
forces de sécurité là vous avez
différentes différents services et toute
la question est de savoir parmi ces
services là qui prêtent allégeance ou
non ou qui du moins pas prête allégeance
peut-être qu'ils l'ont commandité mais
qui ils avaient qui avaient gagné
trigogine qui est Kenny Prigogine c'est
aussi un homme d'affaires il est aussi
originaire de Saint-Pétersbourg il n'est
pas arrivé lui dans le premier cercle de
Vladimir Poutine en relation ne met le
cuistot de Vladimir Poutine il a gagné
Prigogine il a peut-être des comptes de
longue date à régler avec ces oligarques
il y a des c'est à dire que ce à quoi on
assiste aujourd'hui avec toute cet écran
de fumée de denazification de l'Ukraine
de démocratie russe depuis plus de 20
ans la réalité c'est qu'en Russie vous
avez les services qui gouvernent depuis
quasiment la guerre civile russe et vous
avez cette ce cette sorte de mafia qui
est arrivé au pouvoir avec qui on a
vérifié les occidentaux on négocié
pendant des années et on découvre
aujourd'hui on a découvert avec
l'attaque de l'Ukraine et on continue de
voir le visage de ce régime on est en
fait dans un moment de vérité c'est ça
ce que on est dans un on est dans un
roman mafieux
on n'est pas encore dans le moment de
vérité parce que parce qu'il y a encore
peu de gens il y a beaucoup de choses
extrêmement fausses et loufoques qui
sont dites sur cette crise donc on n'est
pas du tout dans le moment de vérité en
me disant
je comprends ce que vous voulez dire on
va être dans un moment de grande
confusion le premier moment de vérité
c'est lorsque Vladimir Poutine a attaqué
l'Ukraine j'étais correspondante en
Russie et à ce moment-là j'ai dit ça y
est on va voir le visage de ce régime
parce que pendant des années en tant que
journaliste en tant que correspondant on
ne pouvait même pas dire que Vladimir
Poutine mentait qu'il avait déjà envahi
l'Ukraine que l'annexion de la Crimée
c'était une invasion de l'Ukraine et que
il était que c'était lui qui avait
provoqué la guerre dans le Dombas c'est
ce que disait il y avait gagné Prigogine
dans cette vidéo on vous a menti il n'y
a pas de bénéfification de l'Ukraine
combien de millions de personnes
aujourd'hui dans le monde croient au
mythe de Vladimir Poutine de
denazification de l'Ukraine en ce sens
oui on va être dans un moment de vérité
mais on n'y est pas du tout encore la
vérité est en train de surgir elle a
commencé à surgir avec l'invasion à
grande échelle de l'Ukraine elle va
continuer à surgir on va devoir se
battre pour bien raconter cette histoire
parce que ça va être très compliqué la
propagande va continuer et les analyses
basées sur le fait qu'on a envie de
savoir tout de suite mais qu'on ne saura
qu'après vont elle aussi continuer donc
il va être falloir être très prudent sur
ces sources d'information mais ce qui
est certain c'est que tout ceci est
historiquement la chute des régimes
dictatoriaux nous le montre les procès
internationaux nous le montrent oui il
finit toujours par y avoir un moment de
vérité dans ces moments historiques